j'avais accueilli dany boon
demain c'est sa meilleure télé depuis
trois ans
je suis
bonjour
alors ces petites amélia landreau a été
appelé une promo il souligna la noyade
est parfait d'une sobriété magnifique
d'alépé unités d'un mouvement européen
c'est sa terrible hénin beaumont jusqu'à
quand et jusqu'à quand il était encore
des interviews parallèle
chaque projet
et maintenant mesdames messieurs comme
on ferait si d'hollywood
ça se passe bien l'européen les gens
n'ont plus besoin de taper tout
d'hénin-beaumont hénin beaumont et à
l'enchaînement hénin liétard faut partir
en vacances demeurent peu et ça s'est
bien passé
très bien tu es venu en hélico là non je
suis venu en voiture et après en moto
pour revenir vite de calmer le jeu je
prends souvent tir ardisson sur l'art et
la moto c'est d'un conte et il a non il
m'a dit accrochez-vous autour de ma
taille c'est ce qui fait lui le fait
tous et aura la dérive est pas mal
jeudi 20 millions moto ouais j'ai un peu
vite plus vite lâche rien et moi j'ai un
foulard sur les très bien non là on
rigole mme alors bon d'écouter medac
alors pas tourné autour du pot trop
longtemps le film dont dany boon vient
parler ce soir et qu'il est merde alors
c'est un super grand film c'est énorme
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
s'appelle joyeux noël c'est un film de
christian carion avec diane kruger
guillaume canet alors le pitcher
fraternisation des troupes françaises
écossaise allemande le soir de noël noël
ils sortent des tranchées et ils se
parlent et ils se serrent la main voilà
et ce film m'a complètement city
l'histoire c'est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire alors l'attaché de presse
dominique segall m'avait dit tu vas
pleurer
il avait raison j'ai pleuré et je vois
pas qui peut ne pas pleurer en voyant ce
film saddam hussein humanité saddam
hussein
c'est un film bouleversant mais vraiment
incroyablement gouverneur parce que ça
fait appel à tous les deux nos bons
sentiments à notre bon côté à la bonne
partie de nous mêmes et c'est un film
qui est très récompensant parce que
quand on sort de là en ce sens meilleur
donc goûté on va pas discuter
voilà un il est tard aller voir le film
puisque j'ai à dire vous ne le
regretterez pas je m'avance pas beaucoup
en disant ça parce que le film a obtenu
une standing-ovation à cannes dont ils
étaient dix minutes voilà depuis dix ans
à venir non mais les gens
applaudissaient pendant la projection un
tournant pour les uns un métier le film
est sélectionné aux oscars à hollywood
donc voila et qu'est ce que voulez que
je vous dise de plus